- Thank you all for coming.
We appreciate you guys
spending your hour with us.
My name's Chris Hallenbeck.
I'm the general manager of
AI and platform for Boomi
and my colleague Thomas Benjamin,
he's gonna be presenting in a minute,
you don't have to come up
but he is the senior vice
president of engineering
and he's gonna come up and
talk about the technical.
So we're basically gonna do talk about
for the first half
to really get into why
governance of agents
and what does that actually mean.
We're really actually not
talking about agents per se,
we're talking about agentic workflows
'cause that's really where
you ended up with the impact.
Not so much, not so much agents,
we'll talk about that more.
But then getting into,
and then Thomas is gonna actually get into
the technical side of things
of how do you actually do this?
Not with your, with your own agents.
That might not be so bad
but our customers are living
in multi-agent worlds.
They're moving in, they
are going to be using stuff
whether it's Anthropic and Open AI
and building stuff in LangChain
and using stuff from Salesforce
and Microsoft and ServiceNow
and how do I actually have
a common governance layer for that
and do that in a way
that I can actually do
true workflows that are governed.
Things like finance,
manual journal entry reconciliation,
doing goods receipt,
invoice reconciliation,
things that an auditor
is gonna come through.
Or if I'm in pharma
and I'm looking at staying compliant
with overall regulatory,
how do I do that in a way?
What do we actually need to
do to become enterprise class?
And that's what we're gonna get into.
But first let's talk about Boomi.
(lively music)
So it's funny to see that,
'cause that's just from a few months ago
and I'm gonna, I actually
show you updated ones.
Talked about 33,000 agents.
That number almost doubled today.
So we will talk a more.
Some of you guys may know Boomi
really well, your customers,
you've enjoyed us for years,
you're extremely passionate
and you're like I know all about you.
And then actually the other one,
which is people either say that completely
or they're like, I've never heard of you.
Which is fair.
'Cause if you're not literally
in the integration space
historically you wouldn't know about us.
Boomi has been around for quite a while.
We have, as you can see
here, over 25,000 customers.
You look at the logos and you're like,
I know almost all of those.
Yes.
And that means they're actually running
their integration processes
on Boomi if they're up here.
800 plus global partners
and over 300,000 users
on our system every day.
People also kind of get into it
and what we've been
known for really of late
is in the right hand graphic,
which was Bea Gartner's Magic Quadrant.
And you're taking a look at
and you're hunting for Boomi
and look in the top right
hand corner and you see Boomi,
and for integration platform as a service,
which is really what we're known for.
What people hadn't known
for which just got released
was the left hand graphic,
which is now you see is
one of the top four vendors
is Boomi the API management space as well
where we've been doing a
huge amount of innovation.
What I always find really
interesting about these charts,
most people look at them as a snapshot
and you actually, it's not.
Everybody is innovating and working
and the requirements to be in that segment
are constantly evolving.
So really what this is, is a window
that is moving upwards
with people with innovation.
Those, and you'll see some
names, you're like, wow,
they're not even in the
magic quadrant anymore.
Those are folks that actually didn't,
their product just stifled.
It just stopped.
People stopped innovating in it.
They might have done some
things, it didn't hit,
they didn't read and
talk to their customers.
And then you see the ones
that actually moved up into that right.
That means they weren't just
moving up at market speed,
they were outperforming
the market dramatically.
And that's what Boomi has been doing.
We could talk about this in
data management and others.
In every segment, Boomi year to year
is going up into the right.
Now why is it, and why are,
why are the analysts saying Boomi
is this one that's kind of on fire.
Why is Boomi listening us
with the biggest companies in the industry
as it pertains to AI and
shortlist of like five,
you see these huge names
and then you're like Boomi, what?
How did they do that?
The key to this is actually
what's in the platform.
So of course we have
integration and automation,
for those are guys who aren't in this
'cause you might come from
the AI space or another area,
integration where we're
taking business processes
that link between multiple systems
and actually directly connecting them.
So those processes can work successfully.
But integration only gets you
common language, common speaking.
To make them work
together takes automation,
all the different steps in there.
And what becomes really important here
is we're beginning to,
we'll quickly get into AI
'cause that's why you all came,
was to actually start to say
some things that I'm hooking
up to, let's say an API,
it might actually be
kind of a very old, old,
old crud based API.
And so where I might have
to actually do a huge number
of invocations to achieve any
given single business process,
creating a customer, generating out,
taking a quote to an order
which either might be
multi-step integration,
Boomi can change all that
and make that in, expose that
as sort of a business level API
and then we handle
everything in the background.
Likewise, you might have
an incredible business API,
which is actually then developed out
and might expose too much capability.
For security and other reasons,
you might actually wanna
create slices of that
of capability and integration
and limit that again through automation,
then exposing that,
just become very relevant
as you start out exposing API
within agentic.
Now we get into data management.
Data management is getting
at two different areas.
We're talking about data management
in terms of data quality.
How can I actually go in
and start creating master data records
or any object that needs to
have extremely high quality
and do that using both
traditional rule-based logic
as well as using agents to
actually cleanse my data,
and actually creating
fully cleaned repositories
of that information?
Now that can be foreign integration
because we know that an integration breaks
when the data doesn't align
on two different places.
Most companies don't have
full master data management systems.
IT is still stuck with a
problem of quality data.
They're the ones dealing
with a catch block
full of errors every
morning when they walk in
and then manually having to fix that.
The business is blaming them
for having written a poor integration,
which in when it was really the business
who wouldn't invest in clean data.
But they're stuck with this.
So what our customers are doing is saying,
I'm gonna solve that
and I use Boomi to automatically
do record cleansing
and then if they wish to
synchronize that data back out
to the transactional systems.
But now that we're actually onto,
so we have those capabilities
in there to move both agents
and rule-based data to
create cleansed data
and actually store that in a repository
if you want for performance reasons.
The next thing that people also want to do
is actually do data integration,
because we have to move the data around.
This is data that is coming
through web services,
APIs, from databases and others
that I need to move,
whether that is from a workday,
from an SAP, from NetSuite
and I need to bring that in.
Obviously that was key
to being able to do that
for master data management
or within an integration
to make sure it's working.
But equally just 'cause
I have to get the data,
Let's say I want to get it
into Snowflake or Databricks
or I want get it into
like an Azure, you know,
into a data lake that I wanna work for.
We have to get that done.
And how do I move that down?
Boomi will auto generate using AI,
the actual extractor endpoint
into things like web services
automatically just by
reading the documentation.
So you don't have to have us support every
different application out there.
We do that automatically.
Then we do the change data
capture on your behalf
to move that data through.
And then it's also, it
has schema evolution.
So as that upstream system
automatically changes,
we notice that, move the data down
in the data serialization format,
update the downstream schema
so that your integrations don't break
as you're doing your
extract transform load
or extract load transform processes
based on what you want to achieve.
Now the big one with
agentic is API management.
And again I said Boomi
has now moved into the top
of the magic quadrant for that as well.
And that is because of
our API control plane.
You have old systems from TIBCO,
you have more legacy
systems from those guys
like Mule or Microsoft
and then you have the more modern systems
from folks like Kong.
And you have those, but now
I need a common control plane
in which I can manage all
those from a security,
from a buffering
and from an overall security standpoint.
But equally now I want to
expose those as MCP servers.
So how can I then expose
various API endpoints?
And this gets to my point
that I made at the beginning
about API management.
You don't just take a raw API
and expose it to an agent
when you're trying to create context.
It can't speak to a crud
API very successfully.
I need to actually take automation code
that then brings that out,
expose out that once I've created
that into a business friendly API
and expose that new API endpoint as,
as an MCP server.
Boomi does that automatically.
Likewise, I may have one
that is way too powerful.
Yes, delete, skim, drop customer
and I don't want to make
everybody have that.
I don't wanna give an agent that ability.
So I cut down the
capability using my code,
using my automation code to
actually bring that down,
narrow down its capabilities
before exposing it as an MCP server.
Then we actually get
down into API management.
And this is the ability not
only to create, we are not,
I wanna say before I get into this,
we are not an AI company.
We are not trying to be Anthropic,
we are not trying to be Open AI,
what we are as a company
that helps you activate AI
in your business processes.
How can I take Anthropic?
How can I take Open AI?
How can I take my own models
that have built in things like LangChain
or any of the other vendors
I mentioned earlier.
How can I leverage those in
my own business processes
where the true value lies?
Now I can't do that unless
I have the enterprise class features,
which means I have the security,
the observability,
the governance
and yes, scalability in order to do that.
And that's what this whole thing is about.
How do we actually get all those pieces
so that once I have my agentic workflows,
I actually have all that in place
so that I can move these into production.
So Agent Studio has first
the ability to build agents.
Agents are easy by the way.
Building an agent takes you like
maybe five minutes on the outside.
Everyone's talking about agents, ooh.
You're like they're really simple.
Now to build one that automatically
has built-in guardrails
lets you add guardrails,
automatically is checking
for things like prompt injection
and yields extremely
high quality responses,
even under multi invocation
with short-term memory built in,
not so easy.
Boomi does that extraordinarily well.
Then beyond that, we also
then have the ability
to then move those into our control plane.
And in that control
plane I can actually take
and manage not only those
agents built by Boomi,
and again, we're not
building our own models,
we're leveraging those
models from major vendors
within your work in, in your work.
I'm then putting that into a place
where I can have complete governance.
I have all that
observability based into it
and I have all the audit
trails that I need.
And not doing it just for
the agents built on Boomi,
but doing it for an entirely
huge host of vendors
so I can have a common control plane
and bring under control to sprawl
that we've been seeing from
all these different vendors.
And how do I begin to manage them
and make sure I don't have
security issues internally.
And then I'm also dealing
with all the governance
issues associated with them.
And then the last point
is how can I then take
those agents trivially
and drop them into my workflow
so they're running headless?
We're all used to conversational UIs,
but in the world in which I live in,
it's all business processes.
How can I take an agent
and just drag and drop it
onto a canvas in which
it's part of my workflow,
a mixed of API endpoints,
pulling that data out
of web services, others.
I've got classic if then
else deterministic logic
mixed through in with agents
and flowing all that
data through from point
to paying using data serialized
format, typically JSON,
but whatever you really,
whatever you love.
What that which we call
"agent step" allows us to use
agents in a true agentic workflow fashion.
True agentic meaning,
I have perception.
I have an agent that gets
called, it has a goal
and it has tools to reach out
and speak to all the different systems
to build its context in
order to do reasoning.
So it can perceive its environment,
it can pull in everything
to create its context.
It will then perceive through
and reason through everything it needs to
to come to a conclusion.
We control all those instructions,
then has the ability to act
by then calling business processes.
So yes, it can go human in the loop
or human on the loop if we
want to involve somebody,
but if you want it directly to say
yes, I did a three-way match onsite,
this good receipt in,
good receipt invoice reconciliation,
notify the ERP that this invoice is good
and they can go ahead and make payment
and by the way, notify
and kick off the process to
the warehouse management system
to automatically receive
the associated goods
and to general availability.
That's exactly what our
customers are using Boomi to do.
So full,
perceive,
reason, act.
And I can do, we can do
that in a conversational UI,
but more importantly our customers do this
directly within process flows.
And then again, Thomas
gonna explain how we do that
with complete governance.
So I can be doing it in that,
in that workflow I just
described, which is in finance
where Ernst and Young's gonna
show up very shortly and audit
and see how you did that
to make sure you have all the information.
And to do that in a world
where I can't not only use a Boomi agent
but I can actually use agents
from all those different vendors
and I can drag them into
Boomi specific processes
if I wanna do that as well.
That comes out in about a month.
And that's what our platform is.
These are the updated numbers.
62,000 agents currently in production.
13,000, sorry, 12,000 of
those are agentic workflows.
The 50,000 are actually people using
built in agents in the Boomi platform
to make Boomi run run better for them.
IT doing this to write their documentation
against their APIs, both
technical and business,
to help them auto gen out
their entire agentic workflows
describing a problem and having
to do that automatically.
These things like Boomi design gen,
so these are prebuilt agents.
And then we have the next 12,000
is where people are actually building out
agent workflows themselves,
partners, customers and others
and deploying those into workflows
and then managing and monitoring those
within Boomi's Agent Control Tower.
Our own, our own results are up there,
97% in reduction in
response time for our own,
we call it Boomi on Boomi
where we use our own platform
to support our own customers.
50% faster issue resolution
and an 80% drop in documentation
time for our own work.
So again, I talk about what an agent is
and I kind of want to hammer this home.
The ability to perceive, reason and act
is truly what agentic means.
Within that, you have tools.
Now everyone's like MCP solves everything.
Well not if it's gonna run
you four or 500 milliseconds
in time on a hop.
Yeah, that might be fine
for a conversational agent,
but that is not okay
for a business process.
I need to be able to have
native tooling to do that.
Boomi allows you to prototype an MCP,
go production if you also want.
I can literally just drag and
drop and go to a native tool,
whether it's an API, a web service,
a database call, et cetera,
all listed out my tools that are reusable.
I drag and drop them in
with full delegated authority.
Now we do that.
That creates the understanding
to build that context window.
Then the agent itself, as you
see on the right hand side,
can actually directly
call off and execute.
It can do task management,
send messages in Slack.
It can go ahead and notify
somebody in a ServiceNow ticket
or it can kickoff a
business process directly
as I talked about like
in the three-way match.
That's what agentic processing is
and this is what is required
to do this at scale.
This is the execution.
And then we're gonna be getting
into the governance side.
Now for a minute,
why do we keep hammering on
this agentic workflow issue?
It's 'cause it's where
the business value is.
We have these things and
most, if you're dealing
and if you deal internally
with your customers
or if you're a partner and you're dealing
with your own clients,
I can tell you they're currently confused.
We built this slide as an aside
and people now it's
like their favorite one.
They keep going, go
back, go back, go back.
Because they don't understand the taxonomy
of what's happening within AI.
They're thinking about things like Copilot
and confusing it with an agentic workflow.
So these things that are
these horizontal systems
like a chatbot or something that is an,
or something that's coding assistant,
like a Windsor for a cursor.
Super cool, not the same thing though.
They confuse those with
what is actually helping
what we're talking about on the bottom,
which is actually dealing with,
with line of business,
specific business processes
and how do I rethink them using agentic.
And that's what we're doing with Boomi.
It's also why we are so
passionate about governance
because these workflows, you have to,
auditors come around and
see what you've been doing.
They don't really care
how you use a chatbot.
They don't care about
how you book your travel
with an AI agent.
These are not the core
processes that help a business.
But it's also actually why you go in
and why McKinsey says
that these systems have
very little business value.
Eight, and you know as they look at it,
of the companies doing it,
McKinsey came out in June
with their CEO report on agentic
and saying eight in 10
companies send gen AI
has had no significant bottom line impact.
And what they do, and they talk about,
you're gonna read the quote here,
there is an imbalance
between horizontal chatbots.
That's what you saw.
Not Windsurf and Cursor,
but the other ones
which have scaled quickly but deliver
diffuse hard to measure gains,
and more transformative vertical use cases
that remain stuck in pilot mode.
Now I happen to come from the team
that wrote this in McKinsey
and I was there, I left right
before they wrote this paper.
So I called 'em up and I said, you guys,
how come when you wrote that
and you quoted the stat there,
was it because it,
was because you can't
get out of pilot mode
because you the piece systems were not
designed with enterprise class features.
And I said security,
governance and observability.
And they said yes, but you
also forgot scalability.
Because if I build something
with like eight different
projects, this open source code,
this customer this, API
management here and there
for one use case,
when I go to scale that up,
they all scale asymmetrically
and all our integration code breaks
and that's only one use case.
They can't even get into production.
Forget about doing this at scale
with hundreds of thousands of
agents from different vendors.
It does not work to do
this without a platform.
And that is exactly what also,
and then everyone's talked
about the MIT study.
MIT came back and said,
actually we think McKinsey
underestimated it.
Here they went in,
the end value here for
the number of projects
looked at was 300
and then they did about
a, there was 152 responses
or thereabouts for written responses
in an academic ridiculous way,
as well as 52 interviews
that were structured.
And they came away and said,
there is only one
definitive causal difference
between the 95% failure
and the 5% successful
from an ROI perspective.
And they said it was integration.
They then came in and said
number two was education.
But the only thing
that was statistically
significant was integration.
Agents are easy.
Giving them the context
through integration
and having all the enterprise
class features to go,
to go live and in production,
that is really hard.
And that was what we
have focused on at Boomi.
So here right now, you can see as we go,
this is talking about,
we have 360 applications on
average in an enterprise,
10,000 APIs.
And we're all used to that sprawl
and the problem that has happened,
40% get one monitored.
We have these ghost APIs,
all these security threats internally.
And then you have over thousands
of data sources and databases.
And now people are worried about,
and we're already hearing
about it extensively,
which is AI sprawl or agent sprawl.
Everybody in the company is
playing with different vendors.
Nobody is thinking about security.
They're literally giving
chat, you know, ChatGPT access
to their financial system
or their HR system.
What could go wrong?
Let's just give 'em a system
password and let it go.
No.
I kid, but it's actually,
you'd be shocked at how many people
think about those things
and didn't really think about
the security implications
or how to have auditing and
logging to know how it happened.
So agentic sprawl is real.
How do you manage it in a
multi-vendor environment?
And I'm gonna leave off here
and I'm gonna have somebody
explain all of this to you,
which is my colleague, Benjamin.
- Thank you, Chris.
(audience applauds)
Chris.
Now like Chris has mentioned,
every organization is struggling
with the sprawl of applications,
APIs, data sources,
and now it's further
compounded with AI agents
and the new challenge it introduces,
which is non-deterministic behavior.
And this is where the Boomi platform
for agentic automation comes into play.
The platform supports a
whole set of use cases,
which you see on the auto parameter,
like lead to cash, hire
to retire, et cetera.
Now the four pillars of the platform
are integration and automation.
So you can essentially integrate
your Salesforce application
to your ERP application,
whether it's Oracle or SAP.
You can integrate Workday to your ERP
or integrate the ERP to ServiceNow,
any kind of permutation and combination.
This is the integration
process that we've had
for over two decades that in
a low-code, no-code manner
that all of you could use.
You could now expose that
integration process as an API.
And with the MCP bridge
capability that we have released,
we can release MCP servers
with a single toggle
where the API can become
an MCP enabled tool
that you can use in your agentic workflow.
And this is where the API
management pillar comes in
where we have API gateways
and a control plane
that Chris talked about,
which helps you federate across
multiple API gateway providers
like Apogee, Kong, Gravity, name it.
We support (mumbles) API providers.
And with the MCP bridge capability,
we can MCP enable every API
that you have within your ecosystem.
And then to complement that
and to set the whole
agentic workflow together,
we have the agent data
management ECA system,
which essentially brings in data
because data is the feeder for AI.
We bring in data through
ETL ELT capability,
traditional methods by EDI,
modern techniques like
ELT change data capture.
And we stitch master data
from multiple applications
that are needed for the
agentic workflows to execute,
whether it's Salesforce,
whether it's ServiceNow,
whether it's Shopify, Oracle, SAP.
We have a seamless mechanism
of stitching master data together.
And this feeds into our agentic ecosystem,
which is developed, run by
our agent management module,
which is made up of four
foundational building blocks.
One is the agent designer,
a low-code, no-code mechanism
by which you can design AI agents
all built on foundational
AWS Bedrock elements.
Next is our agent orchestrator,
which helps you
orchestrate multiple agents
and tools together as part
of your agentic workflow.
And then of course the agent governance,
which gives you the ability
to observe these agents,
look for anomalies, look for
latency within the agents,
and actually perform
actions on the agents.
And as we unpeel the
architecture into a few layers,
I'll actually show you
how this is actually done,
especially with the
case of Bedrock agents.
And then of course we have a marketplace
where all this could be exposed
into the Boomi's marketplace
or also could be exposed
to the Bedrock marketplace essentially.
So this is kind of a
hundred thousand perspective
of the enterprise architecture diagram
for Boomi's agentic automation platform.
Now why do we need to govern these agents?
Like Chris mentioned,
there is a lot of challenges
when you integrate multiple applications.
It's very easy to
integrate two applications,
but when you try to integrate
your Salesforce application
to your ERP system
to incident management system,
the complexity just compounds.
So this is why of governance of agents
coming from multiple providers
and multiple tools coming
from multiple providers
is extremely key.
And that's what we focused on.
The governance is focused
on three core tenants.
First is universal observability,
the ability to observe
the right attributes that you have shared
with the Boomi Agent Control Tower
so that we can collect these attributes,
stitch these attributes,
look for anomalies
and even leading indicators to an anomaly
so that you can do something about it
before an anomaly happens.
And the third pillar is doing something.
As you know, there are no
standards for agents yet.
So the actions that the agent perform
is quite different with each framework.
Some frameworks let you stop, stop,
start, and stop an agent.
Some frameworks let you
quarantine an agent.
So we aggregate all
these different actions
across the different framework providers
so that you can perform an
action when an anomaly happens
across multiple providers.
And in the next few slides and demos,
I'll actually show you how
this all unpeels itself.
The video that you see
on play is just a quick
thumbs eye view of the
actual Agent Control Tower
that we're talking about.
So let me unpeel the
architecture of further layer.
The Agent Studio of Boomi
has got three code building blocks.
First is the agent designer,
and again in the Agent Control Tower,
you don't have to design agents
with Boomi's agent designer.
You can design it from multiple
providers like Bedrock,
Salesforce, LangChain, Crew AI, name it.
But the Boomi agent designer
lets you use natural language
to provide instructions
to design the agent.
It lets you pick your foundation model.
Today we support Cloud family of models.
We've been prototyping newer models
and very soon we'll
open up to other models
from other different providers.
Next is we allow you to expose tools
as APIs, as tools through our MCP bridge,
or you can bring in your own MCP servers
that you can hook up to it
and then you can add memory,
knowledge basis and
guardrails to your agents.
Now once you've designed the agents,
you can execute the agent.
The executing environment for agents
is what we call our agent
garden or agent runtime,
where you have the agent
executor for the Boomi agents,
the tool executor for all the tools
that we MCP enable within Boomi.
And then of course the agent orchestrator,
which orchestrates the activity
or interactions between
these multiple agents
from different providers
as well as different tools
coming from different providers,
not just Boomi.
In addition to that, we
also have a chat interface
that lets you essentially examine
how your agent is performing in action
or multiple agents are
performing in action
in your actual order to cash process
or hire to retire process as an example.
And now let's come to the
Boomi Agent Control Tower.
The Control Tower is
where the real governance
of agents actually happens.
The Control Tower picks up
observability attributes,
and with that you can
actually look in real time
the performance of the agent.
You can look at the token usage,
you can look at the error
rate of the agents, et cetera.
Now to be able to do all this,
there are two key data flows
that we look at from different providers.
The first data flow is metadata.
What is metadata for an agent?
It's attributes like name of the agent,
the tools used by the agent,
the guardrails used by the agent.
And then there are vendor
specific attributes.
So if you're using AWS Bedrock agents,
there are attributes like
aliases, versioning, et cetera.
Similarly, the actions that
you can perform on the agent,
like you can start an
agent, stop an agent.
These are the metadata attributes
that we actually pick up.
The next is the log data.
We get the log data
from multiple providers.
In AWS Bedrock's case,
we get it from essentially CloudWatch
that the customer gives permission
to when they connect
the Boomi Control Tower
to their AWS account.
And we get the log coming into Boomi.
We process the log, analyze the log,
get insights out of the log
to do anomaly detection.
And how we do that will kind of unpeel
that in the next few slides.
We support both push and pull mechanism
for moving log and metadata
between the provider
as well as the Boomi Agent Control Tower.
The Control Tower also supports agents
coming from multiple regions
at this point of time.
Now we not only support ACE, MCP,
and A2A within the Boomi A,
we are also now part of
the agency consortium
that started by Cisco and LangChain
on actively contributing to the evolution
of MCP and A2A protocols.
All the systems within Boomi
are open telemetry compliant,
so you can essentially comply
and hook into any of
your old tel compliant
observability platforms into Boomi
that you use for your respective agents.
Now because we are in
a re:Invent conference,
I want to kind of give a bird's eye view
of the entire Boomi technology stack,
which includes the code
platform and the runtime,
the code platform between integration
and automation data
management. API management
includes building blocks like integration,
flow hub and API, all of
which runs on AWS stack
for more than two decades right now.
And the Agent Studio block,
which includes the agent designer,
the agent orchestrator,
and the Agent Control Tower
are all based on foundational
Bedrock elements.
We use foundational models for Bedrock.
We selectively pick up
services like guardrails,
semantic reasoning, et cetera.
We are also tightly well integrated
into Amazon Quick Suite
as well as Q Business.
The entire engineering
team at Boomi uses AWSQ
as an AI coding assistant
for a lot of our software development.
The beauty with the Boomi platform
is that you can design all
your integrations in the cloud
and you deploy your
integrations into your runtime,
which is a hybrid model.
So if you are having your own AWS VPC
where your systems work,
the runtime runs within your VPC
and not within your Boomi
cloud public environment.
Meaning when you move information
between Salesforce and ERP
or between your HR system and ERP,
it runs within your local parameter,
whether it's your AWS BPC
or any other cloud provider
or any other data center of your choice.
So that's the flexibility we offer
in the hybrid architecture for customers,
which gives them the possibility
to in future support, bring your own LLMs,
bring your own knowledge basis
and such capability as we
deploy agents into our runtime.
But this is kind of a bird's eye view
of the entire Boomi stack
running on AWS foundation.
There are a number of other
services I couldn't show
in the chart like ECS, EKS, Fargate
and a number of other AWS building stock
that we use to scale
and operate our systems
at four nines of availability
at this point of time.
Now, the one thing I
want to highlight is that
the Boomi Agent Control Tower
is a single governance platform,
a control plane to govern
and manage agents and tools,
not just from Boomi,
not just from AWS Bedrock,
but from 30 other providers
including Salesforce,
including LangChain,
including LandGraph, including Crew AI,
and a number of other
open source frameworks.
So anything that you think of it,
we support it at this point of time.
In fact, I have a slide that
I'll get into sometime later
that gives you the entire
gamut of the kind of agents
and tools that we support within
the Agent Control Tower for governance
at this point of time.
So let me unpeel the architecture
and go into another layer deep
in terms of how do we
synchronize metadata.
Metadata meaning attributes
like name of the agent,
the tools used in the agent,
the guardrails in an agent,
the version, the aliases for AWS specific
Bedrock agents, et cetera.
Now on the left hand side,
on the chart on the right here,
you have your AWS Bedrock environment
where you're running your
Bedrock native agents.
Now we essentially use
the Amazon EventBridge
based on the connection that
is set up with your AWS account
and the Boomi Control Tower,
pull the eventing mechanism
that is there for Bedrock
to get all the metadata
in a periodic basis when it's changed
in a pull or push mechanism.
We have support for both.
That information is collected into
the Boomi Agent Control
Tower, or a CT as we call it,
which is built on AWS Fargate.
And in the Control Tower
we process the metadata
and persisted in Aurora DB
with significant
replication provided to it.
When there is an anomaly
observed in a Bedrock agent
from the observability
data that we collected,
if we need to stop that agent,
you essentially invoke the stock command
from the Boomi Agent Control Tower,
and through SQS Lambda
function passes the command
to your Bedrock agent
running in your AWS VPC
to stop the agent at that point of time,
and it gets real time
feedback to the system.
So this is kinda how
we can have seamlessly
integrated this together
so that you don't have
to do any of the work.
We have been working with the AWS product
and engineering teams
for close to a year now
to have cloud formation
templates underneath the surface
to facilitate this integration
in a very seamless manner.
The next is log ingestion.
The second flow I talked about
after metadata was log flow.
We have a similar manner
by which once you hook your AWS account
with your Boomi Agent Control Tower,
you are able to expose
your CloudWatch logs.
Once you've given permission
to Boomi to access it,
it comes through a fire hose
into the Boomi Agent Control Tower
and the Control Tower persisted
in Amazon time-series DB
so that you can go query
the data, analyze the data,
look for anomalies within
the log, et cetera,
and show that in the dashboard.
I'll show that in a demo, but
this is the other log flow,
which also happens in a synchronous
but near real time basis
between the two agents
so that you can get the
logs in a continuous manner.
The third flow is how
do we onboard providers
into the Boomi Agent Control Tower?
I told you you have support
for about 30 plus providers.
We classify providers as two categories.
One is the SaaS vendors like AWS Bedrock,
Salesforce, Microsoft Copilot.
We essentially have a native
onboarding already integrated
with these providers
so that the moment you hook
the two accounts together,
information seamlessly passes in.
In AWS Bedrock keys, we have
a cloud formation template
that is well defined
that ensures that information
from Bedrock metadata
log data are all passed.
And also the agent catalog is passed
to the Boomi Control Tower
so that you can discover it,
govern it, watch it.
When we go to the specific frameworks
like LandGraph or Crew
AI or other frameworks,
we essentially have an onboarding
SDK and an API available
by which you can onboard
all these different agents
from these different providers
into the Agent Control Tower.
Then next is the sync action.
Now how do you synchronize
and metadata between the
two multiple providers
and Boomi Control Tower?
We have two patterns here.
The first pattern is the
pull via pull via API
as well as asynchronous push.
We support this for frameworks
like Amazon Bedrock,
Salesforce, Microsoft Copilot,
and a number of other vendors.
We also have an SDK with
shrink-push API capability
for the custom providers
like Crew AI and LangChain
through which you can synchronize actions
between these different systems.
The last is reporting.
Once we get a lot of the logs,
the logs are processed, analyzed,
analytics are built in the Control Tower
and everything is exposed as APIs.
So that if you want to essentially
hook those APIs back to
your internal dashboard,
you have the ability to call
into those APIs from the
Boomi Agent Control Tower.
So this gives you a high
level handshake mechanism
for a few core things.
How do you onboard providers?
How do you exchange metadata?
How do you exchange log data?
How do you execute actions
from Boomi Control Tower
onto your respective agent providers?
And finally, how do you
get the reporting access?
So we did a lot of talking,
now let's actually see the
Agent Control Tower in action.
So we have an anomaly that's created
in a customer success agent.
The agent is hallucinating
and it's logging out users
when he logs in from multiple devices.
So that's the problem that it has.
So let's see what happens.
The user goes into Boomi's platform page.
You essentially bring up
the Agent Control Tower.
The moment you invoke
the Agent Control Tower,
you see the whole portfolio of agents.
There are agents from Bedrock, Boomi,
Salesforce, ServiceNow, IBM.
When you click on the
anomaly detector tool,
it shows a bunch of anomalies.
So we have one particular anomaly
where there's an increase in token size.
When you look at the anomaly,
we see that the token size exceeds
the current threshold of 300.
The Control Tower automatically
gives recommendations
to adjust the model parameters.
The user looks at it,
reviews it, approves it,
and it's set in action.
Now let's look at one of
the most popular agents,
which is like a Bedrock agent.
Let's click on the agent
and see what's happening
in that particular agent.
We can essentially go into the error panel
and in the panel you can
essentially see invocations,
you can see the token usage,
you can see a list of errors
and there's a spike in errors
and there's basically an error
with a Salesforce agent here.
So when you click on
that Salesforce agent,
you can look at the entire tools,
the guardrails for that Salesforce agent,
and you may want to disable
that agent temporarily
to prevent any other disruption
to your business process,
which you can do.
So what you saw in this video
was a Bedrock agent calling
into a Salesforce agent,
all governed through the
Boomi Agent Control Tower
by going across multiple
providers essentially
seamlessly through all
the different mechanisms
that I just spoke to you
about the architecture,
in the few slides.
I have one more demo to you
that actually shows you
how you can build agents
with the Boomi agent designer.
It's a low-code, no-code utility
where you can go in,
you can give instructions,
you can provide tasks
for the agents as part of the task,
you can essentially look
at a series of tools
that you can add into the task here.
You want to essentially set
the price for the product,
you include that into your list.
You then essentially
look at the guardrails
that are available for the agent.
It gives you a list of guardrails,
attributes and the respective actions.
It also has a demo wizard
where you can actually test the agent
in a sandbox environment in the designer.
You can deploy the agent into
the production environment
or the appropriate environment.
You can then go into the Control Tower.
You can actually click
into one of your providers.
You can look at all the different agents
that are available in the Control Tower
from different providers.
The color code indicates
different providers,
not just Boomi.
You can look at one specific agent.
You can look at the attributes
of that particular agent, essentially.
Look at all the different
tools that the agent has.
You can even go and add new tools
like the hub gen agent
to it as an example.
And then you can look
at the monitoring plane.
The monitoring plane is where
all the log data is collected
to look at your token usage, dashboard,
look at errors and all that.
So this is a whole rich set of
functionality that is offered
and we are continuing to add
more and more new features
into the Boomi Agent Control Tower.
So again, the key thing
here to take away is that
the Control Tower has support for
agents coming from multiple providers,
tools from multiple providers
that you can interact with,
govern with, control and manage
and make sure that your business process
executes in a seamless manner.
I'm gonna skip this slide,
but let's look at what a few
customers are talking about it.
Like Jade Global for example,
we're able to create 20 agents
across different systems like finance,
customer support, customer
success, et cetera,
and deploy these agents into production.
And they were able to save about 65%
of their development time,
6I9, which is another company
which is able to essentially use
the Boomi Agent Control Tower
to essentially govern
across multiple AI projects
that are happening across the enterprise.
So these are some examples
by which companies are
using the Boomi Agent Studio
and the Control Tower
to get governance across multiple agents
and tools coming from multiple providers
in the industry at this point of time.
All this in production at this point.
Now I told you I will share
the list of providers we support.
These are all the list of agent providers
that the Agent Control Tower
today supports in production.
We have Amazon Bedrock.
We have agents from Llama, from Meta,
Salesforce, we have Crew AI,
we have LandGraph, LangChain, name it,
all the top popular providers are there.
We are constantly enhancing this list
to add more and more
providers and capabilities
into the Agent Control Tower
so that you can get control
over the sprawl of agents
and manage them much more
effectively and efficiently
within the organization.
Now in summary, I wanted to leave you
with a few core thoughts.
Our core goal with Agent Control Tower
is to provide scalable AI governance.
Chris had earlier talked about integration
being one of the barriers
of taking agentic workloads to production.
We are trying to address
and solve the problems
because integration has been
within the DNA of Boomi.
We've been in the integration space.
AI agents and agentic
workloads are next new pattern
and paradigm of integration workloads
that's coming into the ecosystem
and we are embracing it right up front
and that's how we have 60,000 agents
in production across different systems.
We give you enhanced visibility.
We work with all the different providers
to make sure that the integrations
with the providers like Bedrock,
like Salesforce,
like Microsoft Copilot,
are seamlessly integrated.
We are also working with
other open source providers
like Crew AI and LangChain
to make sure that it's
closely well integrated.
In fact, with the AWS Bedrock team,
I remember we started this
collaboration about a year ago
where they expose specific
attributes on CloudWatch.
They added poss and play
actions to their agents
so that we could essentially govern it
from the Agent Control Tower.
So that's in summary the core capability
that we provide.
There's more information
that's available on the booth.
Chris, any points you want to add?
- I did.
I want to, when you're
looking at the problem,
there's two parts of the problem.
We just finished a huge study of CIOs
of people that are actually
actively using our system
and we interviewed them all.
What are your top,
and the top three issues
they came back with.
Number one was the difficulty
in understanding the ROI
and the cost of agents to make
sure that that was balanced.
Like what's gonna be the
benefit, risk reduction,
increase in revenue or increase in profit
that I'm gonna get from doing
this balance for the cost
of actually the LLM invocations,
which can be tricky.
You know, we see anything
from two cents to $9
to be honest in our
own production systems.
Hard dollar cost.
All the way up to number
two, data quality.
How can I actually fix
the data quality issue
going in to do that?
Talks a lot about our data hub product,
which is how I could do
master data cleansing.
Doesn't have to be master data,
but how do I actually take
core data concepts that I have
and how do I use both rule-based
and agentic based systems to cleanse those
and create a store
or else how do I actually take my corpus
of documents automatically put those into,
into a vector database
even based on different
document type and others
which we're about to release
without having to have a special engineer
who understands all the different issues
with overlapping and token
size and all the other issues.
And the third issue beyond that
was actually the aspect
of these enterprise class
features of governance.
Now I'm hearing this from
all the top analysts.
They were all telling
me agent sprawl is now
the number two issue after ROI.
We heard it in our own study
that these are coming out.
And I just wanna put this
in your mind for a second,
I'm gonna get to it.
It's the same issue.
Your companies are making,
starting to make decision about AI
and agentic integration for
these business processes.
Many companies now believe,
and if you read whether it's,
you know host of different
analysts are all saying,
within a few years many
of the SaaS providers
will be not doing well.
Your companies will be
disinvesting from those
and be replacing those with
agentic conversational UIs
that work with the different users.
That means your business process
was taken out of the application.
The codification of
that has now moved down
into an agentic layer
that includes APIs, web service calls,
database calls, vector
database calls and others.
That data flowing through
sometimes doing MCP hops,
going through deterministic
logic if then else
and doing probabilistic altogether.
How are you possibly going
to be in a governed state
to make sure that you don't have secure,
somebody hasn't done a prompt
injection and jumped in?
I don't have hallucinations.
If you don't have one system
that can see all the requests out
and all the flows back
in through to the agent,
so then, and then having
something like anomaly detection,
looking for variations
and needles in the haystack
to call attention to those problems.
When the auditor comes calling,
are you gonna go out to
12 different platforms
and start pulling up logs
and trying to stitch those together,
not only with the calls
out but the reasonings
of the different agents
from the different vendors
altogether to show them
how you have complete
immutable audit trails across everything.
That's what we do today in Boomi.
We already do it and
we do it in production.
It's not dream wear, it's not this.
I talked about it.
We have 12,000 of them
in production today.
Okay?
We've been doing this for a while.
We have 50,000 in place in our own system
over the last two years
of people doing it.
We use it in Boomi today.
That's what we're talking about.
This isn't coding it together
with a bunch of different systems
and praying that it works or not,
that you're not here
when the auditors come.
So I'm getting a platform
that'll enable you guys
to then innovate at speed
and actually get that higher
OI from your investments.
So that was the comments I wanted.
- No, thank you Chris.
And again, if you want more information
you can join us at a booth.
It's booth number 1075.
Please come there.
We'll have a lot of our experts out there.
And again, we'll be available
for the next few minutes
outside for us for any conversations
that you may want to have
about how to govern agents
because this is something that Chris and I
and the whole of Boomi
has been doing for a while
at a extreme scale and--
- I'm quite passionate about.
- Yes.
And please don't forget to
fill out the survey forms.
Thank you for your--
- Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)